well especially when it was bad weather
or foul weather we didn't have it indoor
court to go to so we would take our
basketball and go up to the up to the
gym the old Willie eyes at the armory
Yahoo is used to go in there and they
chase us around the police and then we
found the Walker auditorio Walker gym
we're not not many people went to so
we'd go up there and play basketball my
first connection with MIT are
recognizable is probably about when I
was six or seven years old when we were
wandering and they put down granite
floors in the building that we were
going it'd be like belly surfing on the
granite floors sliding on the floors and
go into the revolving door you know or
I'm you know just running around through
there knowing that we're not supposed to
be out of our neighborhood we'd be up
and walking memorial in the gym when it
was cold and we couldn't go to other
facilities and would be playing
basketball and we weren't a group of
kids you know that got in trouble at MIT
we were group of kids that when the MIT
police officers would come and say guys
gotta shut it down you have to leave you
know you're not supposed to be here we
would leave but we would room now we're
moving on to what is called chocolate
city you know which is a minority
dormitory all right you have to get over
the radio station all right so now
you're talking about the 70s and going
into 74 75 where you know out of high
school was still going to the parties
we're listening to the ghetto are we're
going over to the coop you know sitting
up there in the cafeteria up there now
and we fit in